so as we get closer and closer to
election day there are
not surprisingly some numbers that are
not giving me a high level of confidence
that i know
some in my audience already have about
the
seemingly inevitable pending victory of
joseph r biden jr now
i already told you last week that as of
about
22 days out in three key states michigan
wisconsin and pennsylvania hillary
clinton had a bigger lead in 2016
than joe biden had last week we will
update
update those numbers this week but it
was a cause for maybe not concerned but
at least for being very very cautious
there is another signal that given the
realities of the election
is not a great signal for joe biden and
this is both voter registrations in some
states
and mail in ballot requests and even
early voting numbers in some
states and remember why why are we
analyzing it in this way
because this is an electoral college
election
the first candidate to get to 200 the
only candidate to get to 270 electoral
votes
wins overall new voter registrations
and early voting and mail-in ballots
don't matter
it matters in states that would make a
difference if democrats have registered
way more new voters in california great
but joe biden's going to win california
it's not going to move the needle and
get joe biden anymore
electoral votes likewise if we assume
that early voting will be skewed towards
biden
but republicans ask for more mail-in
ballots that would be a red flag and in
the states that could be key
there are some numbers that look good
for trump so
let me give you a couple of examples
despite
michigan polling having joe biden seven
points ahead
in terms of mail-in ballots requested in
michigan
republicans have requested more mail-in
ballots than democrats in michigan so
remember
we were expecting mail-in ballots to be
overwhelmingly biden voters
biden is plus seven in michigan polling
and yet 41-39 republicans have requested
more mail-in ballots and in total if you
combine mail-in ballot
requests plus early votes republicans
have voted more than democrats in
michigan
that's not a number that i look at and
say great
joe biden's got michigan in the bag
similarly if we look at the state of
wisconsin which is a very important
state
ended up being extraordinarily important
in 2016.
despite joe biden leading the polls by
six
in wisconsin republicans in wisconsin
have requested more mail-in ballots by
40 to 38 a small margin
if you include mail-in plus early voting
republicans are down only 38 to 40 and
again
biden supposedly is winning by six there
we expect
biden would win the mail-in vote but
that trump would win
uh the in-person vote on november 3rd
what we are seeing
so far does not correspond with the
expectations based on polling
and preferences about voting by mail
versus voting in person
these are not good numbers now in some
other states things look fine
pennsylvania for example which is
looking like it's going to be a key
state
the numbers in pennsylvania are very
skewed in favor of democrats democrats
requesting way more mail-in ballots
democrats voting early by a huge
majority in pennsylvania it's like 65 to
25
major margin doesn't mean it's over but
the point is
pennsylvania is looking much better
based on what we expected
relative to wisconsin and michigan the
point here is
we're what 15 days out there is no
sense in taking any chances given the
numbers that we are seeing so far
you can find a way to make the numbers
look just great for joe biden just leave
it alone
uh biden is winning today in the popular
vote
by more than hillary was on election day
2016
but that's not the way that this
election will be decided when you
compare
15 days out to 15 days out the numbers
change when you look at registrations
which i want to do the numbers don't
look quite so good let's briefly talk
about that
republicans have registered more voters
than democrats
since the primary elections this year in
the states of
florida north carolina and pennsylvania
that's not good it's very difficult to
extrapolate that one number
to the results we would get on november
3rd but it is
cause for if not concern it is cause for
very
much caution i voted on saturday
i published a video of me voting uh to
my instagram
i used a real ballot dropbox i think i
got about 150
messages from people saying david that
doesn't look like a postal service
mailbox
it's because it's not i used an official
city of boston registered clearly
delineated
well-known dropbox at a state building
it's a real dropbox i didn't mail my
ballot i dropped it off i haven't been
tricked it's okay
let's all do it let me know of course
about any irregularities that you
experience or
any trouble whatsoever that you run into
one of our sponsors today is
lucy and they are giving my audience 20
off lucy is a company founded by caltech
scientists with only one mission
which is to help people quit smoking
and vaping by offering a clean
affordable
nicotine alternative now many of you
know you've heard the stories
i've known several people in my life who
have struggled with quitting smoking
i've seen how difficult it can be and
nicotine alternatives can be hugely
helpful
lucy offers a nicotine gum in three
flavors wintergreen
cinnamon and pomegranate they also have
lozenges which come in
cherry ice flavor lucy is affordable
it'll ship right to your door you don't
have to go out to the store
shipping is always free you can buy
single boxes or save with a subscription
it's the year 2020. it's time to throw
the cigarettes away and get rid of the
vape
and lucy can make it easier you'll find
a ton of excellent
reviews online from countless people who
have used lucy to quit smoking and
vaping
go check them out at lucy.co i've put
the link right underneath this video and
you'll get 20 percent off when you use
the coupon code
pacman and just a quick disclaimer i'm
required to give
these products contain nicotine nicotine
is an addictive chemical